foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my ass remains unwoofed yeah
[Music]
[Music]
wow jeez what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of Rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to Gen 4 when you sleep was the air
horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
his friend
andyx is your best friend being a Hulk
asks for balance
learn
yes so I'm clearly nailing it at all
these things
so I want to go back to life as a lawyer
I I respect that
he doesn't mean that
Centric superhumans are coming out of
the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and I want the She-Hulk to be the
face of it Jennifer Wallace
Namaste I have a serious conflict of
interest this man tried to kill my
cousin Bruce yeah that's quite all right
oh foreign
do your thing good I really miss outfit
I'm not proud of this
Walters we answer to a higher power our
universe is on the edge of a precipice I
am a lawyer who do things by the book
spoke of the Shadow no the book of
American uh laws
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero let's do this
you know that friend you have in high
school
who's way cooler than you were
attractive got all the attention from
everyone
[Music]
they think I'm jealous is that what I'm
feeling
[Music]
foreign
[Music]